- [Tutor] So, a lot of the concepts
that you learn about in
multi-variable calculus,
are really all about
ideas that you originally
might've learned in linear algebra,
and then transferring those to
apply to nonlinear problems.
So for example, I'm gonna
give you a function,
some kind of function that
takes in a 2D vector, xy,
and it's also going to
spit out a 2D vector,
and the specific one I have in mind,
this is just kind of
arbitrary, is x plus sin of y,
and then, because I'm
a sucker for symmetry,
I'm gonna make it y plus sin of x.
Though of course, this could
be any arbitrary function,
you don't need that kind of symmetry.
So, in the last video, I
gave a little refresher
on how to think about
linear transformations
and ideas from linear algebra,
and how you encode a linear
transformation using a matrix,
and kind of visualize it, I use this grid,
and here, I wanna show what
this function looks like
as a transformation of space.
As in, I'm gonna tell the computer,
take every single point
on this blue grid here,
and if that point is xy, I want you
to move it over to the
point x plus sin of y,
y plus sin of x.
And here's what that looks like.
Alright, so things get
really wavy, really curly,
this is not at all a
linear transformation,
all of the lines don't remain lines,
they're no longer nice grid
lines that are parallel
and evenly spaced, in some sense,
there is much, much more information
that goes into nonlinear functions
than into linear functions.
And because this is rather complicated,
I think it might be easy
to see what's going on
if we just focus on a
single individual point.
So let me look at a point
like, hmm, let's say,
pi/2 and zero, okay?
So if that's what I'm
plugging in, x is pi/2,
so at the top here, x
stays the same, it's pi/2,
and then sin of y would be sin of zero,
so that x component is gonna
completely stay the same.
And then for the bottom,
y, or y is also zero,
plus sin of x, sin of
pi/2 is one, and just,
I'll go ahead and write sin of pi/2,
sin of pi/2, but you can think
of that as just being one.
So what that means on the
transformation over here,
is if we look at the point
that's at pi/2, zero,
and pi/2 is a little about 1.5,
so that's gonna be around here,
we expect it to move
to the point pi/2, one.
So it should just move
vertically by one unit,
and if you just focus on that one point
during the transformation,
notice that's exactly
what happens, it just
moves vertically one point.
And of course, things
are quite complicated
because every point is doing that, right?
The computer's taking in every point
and moving it to where it should go.
So, after having given the refresher
on thinking about linear transformations
and encoding them with matrices last time,
something like this might
feel completely intractable.
You certainly have to
store much more information
than just four numbers to
record where everything goes.
But this function has a nice property,
a property that we deal with all the time
in multi-variable calculus.
It's what we call locally linear.
Locally linear.
And what that means is if I
was to take our initial setup,
and then zoom in on a given point,
so I'm gonna zoom in around
this point on the left here,
and this box, kind of in the upper right,
just shows the zoomed-in version of that.
And first of all, I'm gonna
add some more grid lines,
so they're really very close grid lines,
we can see from the zoomed-out picture,
but this just makes it so
that when we're zoomed in,
we can see a little bit
more of what's going on.
And now, when I play the animation,
I'm gonna have this yellow
box that's doing the zooming
follow the point at its center,
so this box will be moving,
and we're always just gonna
look at what it zoomed in on,
'kay?
So it's gonna be following
what's going on around that point
during the transformation.
And we can see, inside
this zoomed version,
it's still not linear, the
lines get a little bit curved,
but this looks a lot more
like a linear function,
it looks a lot more like the grid lines
that started off horizontal and vertical,
are remaining parallel and evenly spaced.
And in fact, let's say
I zoom in even further,
to an even smaller yellow
box here, and again,
I'm gonna add in some more
grid lines right around it,
so they're very, very densely packed.
And this is purely an artifact
of visualizing things,
I could choose to put
points or lines or anything
wherever I want, and I just
think showing the grid lines
and only the grid lines
and where they move,
gives sort of a feel for
what the function is doing.
So this time, when I play
it, and that zooming-in box
kind of tracks the point
that we're looking at,
as it goes, the neighborhood around it,
all of the points around
it, really, really do look
like a linear function.
And the more you zoom
in, the more it looks
precisely like a certain linear function.
Oh, I guess I should've
written an r over here.
Locally linear.
So this raises the question,
if we're looking around
some specific point, which I'll
call x nought and y nought,
this should correspond in some way
to the linear transformation
that it looks like around it.
There should be some kind of matrix,
some two-by-two matrix, that represents
the linear transformation
that this function,
this much more complicated
function, looks like
around that point.
So this idea of zooming in
is what we mean by local,
and in the next video, I'm gonna show you
what this matrix looks like in
terms of partial derivatives
for our original function.
See you then!